[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Heute gibt es einen Eintopf und zwar
machen wir ganz gerne im Herbst
– aber ich muss auch sagen,
ich esse auch im Sommer Eintöpfe.
Denn Eintöpfe, finde ich, gehen einfach das ganze Jahr.
Heute gibt es einen Linseneintopf.
Und zwar nennt sich das Ganze eigentlich saure Linsen,
isch ein schwäbisches Gericht.
– isch...
Jetzt ist es mir rausgerutscht.
Ja, es ist ein schwäbisches Gericht.
Und der Murat mag es auch ganz gerne.
Ich muss sagen, ich habe das ganz lange
– ich kannte das nicht.
Und dann habe ich es aber kennengelernt
und habe es dann auch in das Buch "Sally & Friends" gepackt.
Das war ja unser Charity-Buch,
was wir eben gemacht haben oder was ich gemacht habe
mit euren Rezepten auch darin.
Und da ging ja dann ein Teil des Erlöses
an Oskar, das Sorgentelefon.
Und da habe ich das Rezept auch mit drin.
Heute gibt es
das Rezept für euch jetzt hier auf YouTube.
Und ich mache eine etwas große Menge,
damit wir alle was davon haben.
Und dazu werde ich dann noch Spätzle machen.
Aber das findet ihr dann in einem anderen Video.
Und ja,
und das Ganze ist sogar, wenn ich jetzt so gucke,
fast vegan,
wenn man die Butter weglässt.
Ihr könnt ja statt Butter einfach Öl nehmen
und dann ist der Eintopf wirklich vegan.
Und dann könnt ihr eben
was anderes statt Spätzle dazu nehmen.
Also ich brauche dafür
zwei Zwiebeln,
eine Knoblauchzehe,
ein bisschen Sellerie als Knolle,
Karotten.
Hier habe ich grüne Linsen.
Dann etwas Sonnenblumenöl,
zwei Lorbeerblätter,
Thymian aus dem Garten.
Später für die Mehlschwitze dann Butter und Mehl.
Ich nehme hier etwas Salz,
– da sage ich gleich was dazu –
Pfeffer,
Senf,
ein bisschen Apfelessig
und natürlich Wasser.
Also hier kurz alles zur Seite.
Also ich habe auch Versionen gesehen,
da wird Rauchspeck mit benutzt.
Ich benutze keinen Speck.
Ich will das Ganze auch vegetarisch oder vegan sogar halten
und habe jetzt hier Rauchsalz statt normalem Salz.
So könnt ihr auch ein Raucharoma mit reinbringen,
müsst ihr aber nicht.
Ihr könnt auch ganz normales Salz benutzen.
Also das mit dem Rauchsalz
mache ich heute auch tatsächlich zum ersten Mal.
Was ich jetzt mache:
Ich werde jetzt erst mal die Zwiebeln und die Knoblauchzehe
fein hacken, also schön würfeln.
In der Zwischenzeit gerne auch schon mal
das Öl erhitzen,
einfach in einem großen Topf.
Ich nehme jetzt hier den Gusseisentopf.
[Musik]
Ein schwäbisches Sprichwort sagt:
"Die Hände müssen nach Zwiebeln riechen
nach einem gelungenen Arbeitstag."
Oder, Josh?
>> JOSH: Ja. Ich kenne das Sprichwort nicht,
aber ich stimme dir zu.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Ich kenne es auch nicht. Ich habe es erfunden.
Und was gibt es noch zu beachten?
Grumbiere (Kartoffeln) nicht neben den Zwiebeln lagern.
Da gab es mal die Werbung.
Kennst du nicht?
>> JOSH: Bin ich da zu jung dafür?
>> SALLY: Wow! Bin ich zu alt dafür?
>> JOSH: Ich weiß nicht.
Ich sage jetzt nichts Falsches.
>> SALLY: Da gab es mal so ein Video.
Das ist mal so rumkursiert.
Kennst du nicht dieses
"Soundso viele Millionen Deutsche
können nicht richtig lesen und schreiben"?
>> JOSH: Ja, ja.
>> SALLY: Und das gibt es in schwäbischer Version.
Und das ist dann so:
Dann schimpft der mit ihm und sagt so:
"Grumbiere net neben den Zwieble!"
Und dann ist es eben so:
"80 Millionen Deutsche können kein richtiges Schwäbisch."
Also jetzt die Zwiebeln schön anbraten.
Immer mal wieder durchrühren.
Und den Deckel drauf.
Dann riecht es nicht so stark nach Zwiebeln.
Oh, meine Augen!
Wow!
Ich weiß, ihr schreibt mir immer wieder eure Tipps rein,
Wasser im Mund.
Ich weiß, ich muss es
– ich denke immer zu spät dran
und außerdem moderiert es sich schlecht
mit Wasser im Mund.
Es ist halt echt so!
>> JOSH: Pfeifen.
>> AYLIN: Taucherbrille auf.
>> SALLY: Oder Taucherbrille auf
sieht halt auch ein bisschen komisch aus.
Ja, was soll ich tun?
Jetzt noch die Karotten und den Sellerie
schön fein schneiden,
einfach in feine Würfel.
[Musik]
Sarah, du als waschechte Schwäbin,
kannst du mal kurz ins Video kommen?
>> SARAH: Warum?
>> SALLY: Komm.
Sarah, du als waschechte Schwäbin,
>> SARAH: Ja.
von dir würde ich gern wissen:
Wo ist dein toller Jumpsuit her?
Okay. Nee, das war nicht die Frage.
Also die Frage...
>> SARAH: Du musst hinten reingucken.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Ich gucke.
Oh, cool.
Eine Frage...
>> SARAH: Sag es den Leuten.
>> SALLY: Nö, ich sage es nicht.
Ich will ja keine Produktplatzierung machen.
Nee, was ich fragen will:
Kennst du diesen Werbespot?
Dieses
"Wie oft habe ich gesagt:
'Grumbiere net neben Zwieble lagern'?"?
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ta-daa!
>> SARAH: Grumbiere,
aber das weiß die Hälfte nicht.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Das weiß die Hälfte nicht.
Und der Josh hat gerade behauptet,
er kennt den Spot nicht, weil er zu jung ist.
In Schlussfolgerung: Ich bin zu alt.
>> SARAH: Aha!
>> SALLY: Aha!
>> JOSH: Das war nur eine Hypothese.
>> SARAH: Du bist doch fast gleich alt wie wir.
>> SALLY: Ja, ich bin doch auch nur Mitte
– Anfang 20.
>> SARAH: Sie ist doch auch eine Zwanzigjährige.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Wie so zwei Zwanzigjährige, Sarah.
>> SARAH: Also ich gehe jetzt her und hole
dein Däbbdulup, gell?
>> SALLY: Das habe ich mir fast gedacht.
>> SARAH: Ha ja, nicht?
>> SALLY: Können wir bitte später das Video so beenden?
>> SARAH: Ha ja.
Wir beenden es schwäbisch.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: So. Ich habe jetzt einfach
ein bisschen mehr Sellerie rein, als ich wollte.
Aber ich finde Sellerie gut.
Deswegen kommt er mit rein.
Hier kommt das Gemüse jetzt einfach dazu.
[Musik]
Jetzt schön mit anbraten,
gerne so eine Minute.
Ich gebe auch schon mal die Lorbeerblätter dazu
und werde schon mal die grünen Linsen
in einem Sieb einfach kurz abspülen.
[Musik]
Das riecht schon wunderbar.
Jetzt kommen die Linsen dazu.
Und ich bin echt so ein Fan von viel Gemüse.
Falls ihr jetzt mehr Linsen haben wollt und weniger Gemüse,
könnt ihr natürlich den Gemüseanteil auch
ein bisschen verringern, indem ihr es aus dem Topf haut.
Nee. Aber ich muss schon sagen, Gemüse muss schon sein.
Also so kriegt man auch die ganzen Vitamine rein.
Gut, und Hülsenfrüchte, die Linsen, sind ja auch supergesund.
Von daher wird das echt ein ganz, ganz tolles Menü heute.
Kurz mit anbraten.
Und jetzt kann ich hier direkt schon
mit dem Wasser aufgießen.
Ich gebe jetzt noch kein Salz dazu.
Denn Salz bewirkt,
dass die Linsen eben nicht so schnell gar werden.
Das gebe ich eben erst mal ganz zum Schluss dazu.
Ich habe fast kurz den Faden verloren beim Reden so.
Aber dann habe ich ihn wieder gefangen.
So.
Direkt auf höchster Stufe, damit es kochen kann.
Thymian aus dem Garten kommt auch mit rein.
Und die restlichen Zutaten warten noch.
Jetzt schön aufpassen.
Und da ist auch eigentlich eine ganz gute Info:
Die Linsen müssen jetzt nicht komplett weich sein.
Also die dürfen schon noch ein bisschen Biss haben,
so al dente sein.
Das dauert jetzt so ungefähr 15 bis 20 Minuten.
Und in der Zwischenzeit
– nee, so in zehn, fünfzehn Minuten
mache ich die Mehlschwitze.
Ich mogle halt ein bisschen.
Ich habe zwar gesagt Eintopf,
aber wir nutzen zwei Töpfe,
weil ich die Mehlschwitze noch mache.
Ihr müsst sie nicht machen, aber ich finde,
wenn man jetzt das Mehl
einfach nur mit Wasser verrührt und reingibt für die Bindung,
ist okay, kann man machen,
aber einen besseren Geschmack gibt es eben,
wenn man das Mehl in der Butter
noch ein bisschen andünstet.
Und deswegen ein zweiter Topf.
Ich hoffe, ihr verzeiht mir.
So sieht es jetzt bereits aus.
Ich finde, das sieht lecker aus.
Und jetzt kann ich hier in meinem zweiten Topf
– Twopot, Twopot-Gericht –
bereits die Mehlschwitze machen.
Das heißt, da kommt jetzt die Butter rein.
Und noch einmal: Wenn ihr es vegan machen wollt,
vegane Butter oder einfach Öl nehmen.
Das Mehl dazu.
Und das wird dann schön angebraten,
bis es so leicht hellbraun wird.
Dadurch verliert es den Mehlgeschmack
und bekommt einfach ein schönes Aroma.
Ich nehme jetzt hier schon mal die Kräuter raus.
Zack, zack!
Gerne auch schon die Lorbeerblätter raus.
Die will man auch nicht unbedingt mitessen.
Sehr gut.
Ich mache jetzt den Sturmi
und mache jetzt hier PowerBoost.
Schnell, schnell, schnell, schnell!
Anschwitzen!
So.
Vielleicht wieder runter von der Power-Stufe.
Wenn es dann anfängt, gut zu duften,
und eben leicht braun aussieht,
könnt ihr hier von der Brühe was dazu geben
und schön dabei rühren,
damit es nicht klumpt.
Und dann kommt jetzt hier alles zu den Linsen dazu.
Und das bindet dann eben den Eintopf schön,
damit es nicht so suppenartig ist,
sondern wirklich so schön ein Eintopf ist.
Njam, njam, njam.
Und jetzt mit dem Essig abschmecken.
Dann Salz.
Wie gesagt, habe ich jetzt hier ein Rauchsalz.
Senf dazu.
Dann noch mit Pfeffer abschmecken.
Und jetzt nur noch kurz erwärmen,
bis das Ganze eben bindet.
Und dann ist der Linseneintopf im Prinzip schon fertig.
Bei uns gibt es jetzt hier ganz traditionell
selbst gemachte Spätzle dazu.
Da habe ich, wie gesagt,
schon ein eigenständiges Video dazu.
Und was auch gut passt, sind Wienerle.
Wir nehmen jetzt Rindswürstchen.
Und die werde ich dann gleich
im Spätzlewasser noch mit erwärmen.
Und dann kann schon probiert werden.
Sarah, kennst du das?
>> SARAH: Ja.
Ich muss sagen, als Kind habe ich das gehasst.
>> SALLY: Ich glaube, jeder hat es als Kind gehasst.
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Aber später liebt man es.
>> SARAH: Meine Mutter wollte mir das immer andrehen.
Dann habe ich immer gesagt: "Nee.
Ich esse ein Brot."
Und dann irgendwann bin ich älter geworden,
älter und schlauer und reifer.
>> SALLY: Und du legst mehr Wert auf gesunde Ernährung.
>> SARAH: Ja. Und dann habe ich gemerkt,
Linsen sind eine super Proteinquelle.
>> SALLY: Ganz genau.
Hülsenfrüchte allgemein.
>> SARAH: Linsen sind eine super Proteinquelle.
Deshalb
>> SALLY: Essen wir Linsen.
>> SARAH: essen wir Linsen.
>> SALLY: Ja. Und guck,
in dem Buch habe ich es als saurer Murat gemacht,
weil das aussah wie so ein Gesicht.
>> SARAH: Aber der guckt da gar nicht sauer.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SARAH: Wer hat das dekoriert?
>> SALLY: Ich.
>> SARAH: Schön.
>> SALLY: Foodstyling...
>> SARAH: Note 6.
>> SALLY: Aber das ist ja auch ein Kinderbuch.
Deswegen soll er freundlich gucken.
>> SARAH: Ach so.
Ja, sonst kriegen die Kinder Angst vor diesem Wurstmund.
>> SALLY: Und sauer macht lustig.
Wurstmund!
Probier einfach.
>> SARAH: Okay.
Ich bin gespannt.
Oh! Ich habe es aber noch nie mit Karotten drin gesehen.
>> SALLY: Ja, ich wollte halt noch Gemüseanteil.
>> SARAH: Finde ich gut.
>> SALLY: Darf ich kurz meinen Löffel
– da mit dem?
>> SARAH: Das darfst du.
>> SALLY: Mit Spätzle.
Also...
>> SARAH: Da ist so eine Fliege. Sieht man die?
>> SALLY: Ja, die will auch.
>> SARAH: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Hm.
Das Beste an einem kalten Herbsttag.
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Oder an einem warmen Sommertag.
Egal.
>> SARAH: Auch das.
Weißt du, wie wir das immer essen?
>> SALLY: Hm?
>> SARAH: Noch extra Essig drauf.
>> SALLY: Hm.
Also ich...
>> SARAH: Immer Essig drüber.
>> SALLY: Ich tatsächlich auch.
Ich würde jetzt hier auch noch extra Essig dazu machen.
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Weil dann ist es wirklich richtig sauer.
>> SARAH: Richtig schön sauer.
>> SALLY: Hm.
So mag ich es auch.
Murat würde jetzt dazu so ein Rindswürstchen essen.
Ich finde, es muss nicht sein.
Weil das ist so schon
– mir würde auch der Eintopf schon reichen,
also ohne Spätzle, muss ich echt auch sagen.
Denn es ist ein sehr sättigender und sehr leckerer Eintopf.
>> SARAH: Proteinreich.
>> SALLY: Und proteinreich, wie wir wissen.
Also probiert das Rezept gern mal aus.
Vielleicht habt ihr ja auch ein Rezept,
was so typisch ist für eure Region.
Also so saure Linsen, glaube ich, kennt man nicht überall.
Josh, kanntest du das?
>> JOSH: Ja, schon.
>> SALLY: Hier in Baden
– ich glaube, hier in Baden kennt man es noch, nicht?
Ab und zu.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Max, Bayern?
>> SARAH: Bayern...
In Bayern nicht?
>> SALLY: Nicht?
>> SARAH: Ich hätte jetzt irgendwie gedacht Bayern.
>> SALLY: Ja. Vielleicht habt ihr ja auch
so ein typisches Gericht aus eurer Region.
Dann schreibt es doch gerne in die Kommentare.
Und dann machen wir es für euch.
Also viel Spaß beim Nachmachen!
Bis zum nächsten Mal! Tschüss!
>> SARAH: Tschau!
Tschau!
[Musik]